Guten Morgen, Stefan.
Es ist Sommer.
Naja, also Sommer vielleicht noch nicht. Es ist noch ein bisschen kühl abends.
Ich hab Leute gesehen, die eröffnen schon ihren Pool und so.
Tatsächlich. Es regnet ja nicht mehr, das ist eigentlich sehr dramatisch. Für uns ganz gut, aber ja.
Genau so ist es, es regnet. Ich hab dir eben schon im Vorgespräch gesagt, ich habe diese Woche noch nichts konsumiert. Und du hast mir gesagt, du hast Clips mitgebracht für den Teaser.
Ich dachte, so ein paar Clips muss man vielleicht doch einbringen, sonst ist der Monat zu lang. Wenn wir diese Clips erst in vier Wochen spielen würden, dann ist es eigentlich schon wieder passé. Wir müssen uns vielleicht auch mit ein bisschen Galgenhumor dem Thema Krieg nähern. Das ist etwas, was bei mir sehr stark ausgeprägt ist, der Galgenhumor. In gewisser Weise auch eine gute Abwehrreaktion auf alles, was da so auf einen einprasselt. Und dann sah ich in der Kulturzeit einen eigenartigen Bericht. Also man sieht da ja des Öfteren eigenartige Berichte. Aber dieser war besonders eigenartig. Und zwar haben wir es hier mit einem Künstler aus Litauen zu tun. Er heißt Marius Ivashkivy Kyrs. Und dieser Künstler wird auch zum Krieg befragt. Warum ist mir eigentlich nicht klar. Also er ist in Litauen. Ja, das hat auch irgendwie was mit geopolitischen Sachen zu tun. Aber es ist immer für mich diese große Frage, warum man glaubt, plötzlich jeden befragen zu müssen zu so einer weltpolitischen Einschätzung. Man kann ja was über die Situation der Kunst sagen oder man kann etwas dazu sagen, wie die Kunst auf den Krieg antwortet. Aber ich finde es schon sehr erstaunlich, dass es so eine Identitätspolitik bei der Berichterstattung gibt, dass man immer versucht, jemanden zu erreichen, der irgendwie aus dem Land kommt oder in der Nachbarschaft lebt oder sonst was, wo man sich ja mal das fragen könnte. Nehmen wir mal an, man wäre jetzt im französischen Fernsehen tätig. Und in Deutschland gibt es zum Beispiel eine Bundestagswahl. Und dann würde man auf die Idee kommen, ach, man könnte ja eigentlich mal meinen Onkel anrufen, was der dazu sagt, und schalten den mal zu. Das wäre total absurd. Aber hier reicht irgendwie so dieses ist mal durch Russland spaziert oder so, um was sagen zu können. Und entsprechend verrückt fallen aber auch dann die grundsätzlichen Bewertungen der Lage aus. Wir hören da vielleicht mal den ersten Clip.
Bis zu diesem Krieg war ich immer der Meinung, dass ich zu 100 Prozent Pazifist sei und dass ich niemals zur Waffe greifen würde.
Doch dann habe ich verstanden, sollte es in meinem Heimatland Litauen Krieg geben und ich nicht zu alt dafür sein, dass ich zu 100 Prozent in den Krieg ziehen würde. Ich weiß zwar nicht genau wie, vielleicht nicht als Soldat, aber vielleicht würde ich eher mit dem Kopf arbeiten.
Ja, das ist für mich die Situation, in der ich zum Galgenhumor übergehe, denn erst hören wir jetzt jemand, der sagt, ja, auch ich bin bereit, mich für, weiß ich nicht, die Demokratie oder was weiß ich, zu opfern. Und dann stellt man aber irgendwie so beim Reden noch fest, ach so Krieg, so mit Waffen da irgendwie rumhantieren, im Feld, im Graben. Also mit dem Kopf würde man vielleicht arbeiten. Also was er eigentlich ja sagt, ja, ich würde natürlich alles wie immer machen, ich bin halt Künstler.
Ja, das ist total verrückt. Also wir können es ja noch enger ziehen als dein Beispiel von eben. Eintracht Frankfurt hat gestern im Halbfinale der Europa League West Ham United offenbar besiegt mit 1 zu 0. Was ich hier in Frankfurt am Main nicht mitbekommen habe, also du hättest mich anrufen können und dir einen O-Ton bei Frankfurt und so und ich hätte dir nichts dazu sagen können. Mir ist es aufgefallen, weil mir Google News heute Morgen eine Story vorschlug, dass West Ham Fans auf dem Römer eine dort stattfindende Hochzeit gecrasht haben. Also das Paar kommt aus dem Standesamt, steht auf dem Römer, lässt sich fotografieren und plötzlich sind da tausende Fans, die sich drumrum singend und so weiter und das Foto entsprechend aufwerten. Also der Beutigam fand es ganz lustig. Das ist sozusagen meine Einflugschneise in dieses Thema und das klingt hier bei Marios genauso. Also man hat so einen Bezug irgendwie und dann sucht man seine Einflugschneise und stellt dann währenddessen fest, ach so, ja, da fand ja noch eine Hochzeit statt und deswegen so. Und dann biegt man sich das so zurecht.
Und wie leichtfertig Leute plötzlich bereit sind, sich für irgendetwas zu opfern. Das ist ja, also das macht er natürlich nicht. Er zieht sich ja raus, er wird sich dann um ein Stipendium beim Goethe-Institut in Italien oder so bemühen und dann von dort aus sicherlich auch intervenieren. Aber es ist erstaunlich, wie man gleich so eine Stimmung herstellt, sich für irgendetwas zu opfern, wo ich auch mal frage, aber was denn, welches Stück Land denn jetzt gerade, für wen eigentlich, dafür, dass Diana zu Löwen weiter Insta-Stories machen kann, für den neuen Spotify-Podcast? Ja, nein, man kann das ja auch einfach mal so formulieren, denn wenn von mir die maximale Einsatzbereitschaft gefordert wird, dann muss ich ja auch was dafür geboten bekommen. Und da bin ich mir nicht so sicher. Wenigstens Steuervergünstigung oder so, sehr eigenartig. Aber es ist ganz typisch. Und ich frage mich auch, was da eigentlich die journalistischen Standards noch sind bei einer Sendung wie Kulturzeit, dass man das dann abspielt. Also man könnte ja auch einfach sagen, gut, wir haben dieses Interview geführt, es war nicht besonders geistreich, wir lassen es weg. Das passiert ja immer wieder. Aber offenbar denkt man, man muss jetzt alles versenden, was in diese Richtung geht. Und wir hören jetzt noch einen zweiten Clip von diesem Künstler Marius, der jetzt nochmal Putin, Atomkrieg, all das auch für uns einschätzt. Und wir überlegen mal, ob wir vielleicht nicht doch dann eher Scholz und Macron vertrauen.
Putin lebt in der Vergangenheit und sieht sich selbst als historische Gestalt.
Aber er will nicht in die Geschichte eingehen, als der, der die ganze Welt mit Atomwaffen zerstört hat.
Ich glaube, er sieht das rational. Er wird das nicht tun. Daran glaube ich fest. Denn das ist zu viel für ihn. Für ihn war es jetzt schon zu viel, Haarkiff und Kiev einzunehmen. Städte, die eigentlich durch nichts geschützt waren, nur durch Ukrainer mit alten sowjetischen Waffen. Aber für das ganz große Ding hat er einfach zu kleine Eier.
Ich überfrage mich, muss man das noch kommentieren?
Eigentlich nicht. Es spricht für sich, es spricht für das Niveau der Debatte. Wenn wir so darüber reden, dann kann man immer nur froh sein, dass der Scholz-Homad regiert.
Das muss man wohl echt so sagen. Gerade wenn man ja weiß, dass Olaf Scholz gerade auch sehr viel mit Verwaltungsabläufen und so zu tun hat. So wie habe ich ja auch. Wo stehen die Kesselwagen? Wo sind die Häfen? Wer kann überhaupt irgendwas schnell bauen und so? Wo liegen die Leitungen? Wer bezieht dir von wem Energie? Und genau so muss man sich ja auch, oder könnte man sich ja nochmal den Krieg anschauen, welche Doktrin gilt eigentlich gerade? Welche Befehlshaber führen Befehle aus? Mit wem könnte man nochmal reden und so? So auf der Ebene. Stand jetzt alles so auf Putins potenziellen Einsatzbefehl. Das hatten wir ja schon mal bei der Donald Trump Wahl. Da haben wir dann später auch gelesen. Bei was? John Bolton, eins dieser Bücher. Wie Bob Woodward wahrscheinlich. Wie Pelosi da nochmal anrief, weil sie wusste, bei welchem Militär kann ich mich nochmal darüber informieren, wie das jetzt genau abläuft mit den Atomwaffen und sich da nochmal die Beruhigung holen. Auf der Art und Weise hofft man ja, dass die Bundesregierung und alle eingegliederten NATO und so weiter jetzt auch operieren und das hier wirklich nur Späße für die Öffentlichkeit sind.
Ja, aber sehr traurige Späße und dass das dann eben immerhin in dem neben Arte wichtigsten Kultursender stattfindet, ist für mich eigentlich überhaupt nicht mehr verständlich. Also dass man sich auf dieses Niveau herabbegibt und glaubt, das dann senden zu müssen, das ist so ein Zertreten von allem, was eigentlich intellektuelles Fernsehen sein könnte, dass ich da eigentlich auf diese Weise mehr empört bin als jetzt über diese konkrete Aussage, bei der man aber auch schon ja im Sprechen merken müsste, dass da was nicht stimmt. Also ich unterstelle jemandem Rationalität, argumentiere aber immer nur mit meinem eigenen dumpfen Gefühl, ich glaube, also entweder kann ich ja Rationalität dann auch rational begründen, aber einfach nur dazu sitzen, ich glaube, ist ja vollkommen verrückt und das ist ja eigentlich das, was auch in den vergangenen Jahren immer stattgefunden hat, also auch immer der Glaube daran, dass Putin das dann nicht machen wird. Und jetzt glaubt man wieder irgendwas anderes gerade und dann sagt man in ein paar Jahren, ach, da haben wir mal wieder falsch geglaubt. Das ist sehr, sehr eigenartig, in welcher Art und Weise da über geopolitische Strategie auch gesprochen wird. Also wir werden ja im Salon gleich auch einen Text besprechen, der nur dokumentiert ist, also nicht in dem Sinne, dass man sagt, hier, es ist ein Autor, den haben wir mal angefragt von den Blättern. Könnt ihr mal, kannst du mal aufschreiben, wie ist das jetzt mit dieser angeblichen Entnazifizierung der Ukraine, sondern die dokumentieren einfach mal diesen propagandistischen Text. Und der macht einen sehr wütend, aber vor allem ratlos. Und die Frage stellt sich dann auch, ist das jetzt tatsächlich so ein Text eines Chefideologen in dem Sinne, dass Putin davon beeinflusst ist? Oder ist das ein Argumentationsmuster, das man auch anbietet für Teile der russischen Bevölkerung? Und selbst hat man nochmal ein ganz anderes Kalkül. Das ist auch das, was Habermas umtreibt. Das ist ja auch ein Text, über den wir sprechen werden.
Ja, was uns hier so in die Irre führt, ist, du hast jetzt sehr inhaltlich das aufgegriffen, ist natürlich auch dein Verweis auf die Mitteilung. Die Kulturzeit erleidet ja auch diese Hyper-Politisierung irgendwie seit Corona, dass man nicht mehr drum rumkommt. Die Kulturzeit hat dann das Sonderproblem, dass natürlich die ganze Berichterstattungsthematik einfach ausgefallen ist, dieser ganze Kulturbetrieb. Und jetzt, und das sieht man häufiger, wollen sie politische Sachen aufgreifen, aber immer so, dass sie von sich selbst sagen, und das haben wir zu Recht bei uns gespielt und nicht den Tagsthemen angeboten als Beitrag. Und dadurch suchen sie immer so ein Dreh, so ein Einfallstor, so ein Winkel. Und dann kommt eben auch so was bei rum. Das ist ein bisschen schade, ehrlich gesagt, weil das so eine, wie soll man sagen, nicht bewusste, aber so eine umschiffene Defizitberichterstattung ist. Man könnte ja auch sagen, komm, es sind politische Zeiten, also machen wir jetzt mal eine politische Woche. Es ist ein echter Krieg, also das auch mal anerkennen. Und das nicht nur so als Thema unter anderem, das haben wir auch schon besprochen, dann trotzdem ins gewohnte Format einzuzwängen.
Oder ich wäre auch sehr gern für ein Gegenprogramm. Es gibt ja auch noch andere Dinge. Es werden noch schöne Abende veranstaltet mit Streichquartetten oder sonst was. Und dann soll man einfach darüber berichten. Also dann kann man einfach sagen, da ist das. Genauso wie man Fußball spielt und sagt, hier wird jetzt Fußball gespielt. Jetzt ist hier nicht gerade das Thema Waffenlieferung, sondern hier spielen die jetzt 90 Minuten Fußball. Und so kann man auch sagen, es gibt eine Neuinzenierung einer Bellini-Oper. Und darüber diskutieren wir jetzt.
Mal sehen, in England gab es ja, als der Druck richtig groß war, Nachrichtensender, die gesagt haben, hier gibt es Nachrichten ohne Brexit. Obwohl das natürlich das alles dominierende Thema war. Dann gab es einen Sender, der hat gesagt, hier sind Brexit-free-News.
Sehr gut.
Und vielleicht traut man sich ja sowas mal.
Eigentlich wäre das genau das Richtige. Und ich würde gerne auch was über Kommunikation und die Rezeption von Kommunikation sagen. Ich finde es ja doch ganz erstaunlich, dass inzwischen alle in diesem Rezeptionsmuster gefangen sind, dass man immer schaut, welche Ästhetik, welche Stilmittel, welche Rhetorik finden wir vor, wenn Politiker sich äußern. Und dann kennen wir diese berühmten Heiko-Mas-Bilder oder wir kennen jetzt auch Baerbock, wie sie da mit Wassereimern durch die Gegend läuft. Und dann sehen wir aber auch Habeck, der eine direkte Ansprache wählt in die Kamera. Und jetzt kann man sagen, ja, das ist auch so ein bisschen der Video-Blog, der da veranstaltet wird, wie wir das noch aus frühen YouTube-Zeiten kennen. Das ist vielleicht auch eine Influencer-Ansprache. Aber es bleibt dann oft nur bei dem zu sagen, er setzt ein gutes Signal. So spricht man mit den Menschen auf Augenhöhe und all das. Ich würde aber mal gerne da bei Habeck den Fokus verschieben. Ja, das stimmt alles und das kann ich auch so rezipieren. Und dann kann ich sagen, das ist eine neue Art der Ansprache, die da gewählt wird, eine Ansprache, die Merkel nie konnte. Sie hatte ja auch diesen Podcast, aber hatte eigentlich immer nur neuer Ansprachen gehalten. Und zwar das Runde Jahr über. Aber bei Habeck ist ja noch etwas ganz anderes. Wir haben eine inhaltliche Auseinandersetzung dort, auf einem hohen Niveau. Eine Auseinandersetzung, die nicht so aussieht, ich versuche einfach nur, jetzt meine Politik kurz zu verkaufen, auf ein paar Schlagworte zu reduzieren. Sondern was er ja eigentlich macht, ist Wirtschaftspolitik, die Bedingtheiten, Abhängigkeiten von Wirtschaft zu erklären. Mit anderen Worten, ich wäre sofort bereit, ihm einen Job bei Wohlstand für alle anzubieten. Also er macht eigentlich einen Wirtschaftspodcast dort. Er beschreibt, was das jetzt bedeutet, wenn wir sagen, wir wollen kein Öl mehr importieren von den Russen. Dann haben wir folgende Probleme. Da gibt es noch diese und jene Verträge. Und dann versucht er, das aufzuschlüsseln und einen Weg zu zeigen, wie man dann da rauskommt. Das heißt, es geht hier nicht einfach nur, ich mach dem Bürger irgendwas transparent, setze ein Signal, so wie das dann alles immer formuliert wird. Sondern es geht hier im ganz fundamentalen Sinne um Aufklärung über die Politik und über die wirtschaftlichen Zusammenhänge. Also er leistet eigentlich das, was Journalisten leisten müssten. Und wo Journalisten aber einfach sagen, jetzt müssen wir für die Freiheit frieren, jetzt drehen wir mal alle die Heizung runter, jetzt müssen wir aktivistisch werden, da kommt jetzt der Politiker Habeck und macht Wirtschaftsjournalismus und sagt, nun folgende Schwierigkeiten ergeben sich, wenn.
Ja, während du das so beschrieben hast, habe ich mich wieder dran erinnert, wie damals publizistische Debatten geführt wurden. Ist ja nicht unähnlich der Politik. Man hat halt Oppositionen hier und Regierungen so ein bisschen da. Also die großen Zeitungen und dann die kleinen. Und dann gibt es irgendwie den einen, der eine macht so einen Debattenaufschlag und die andere Zeitung reagiert. Oder man führt eben alles im selben Blatt. So hintereinander weg. Die Blattlinie ist, am Montag kommt Dienstagtext und am Mittwoch, und das wird dann auch schon angekündigt, kommt dann dieser, sodass gar keine andere Zeitung zum Zuge kommt. Es sei denn, ihr fällt nochmal was Besonderes ein. Aber so Politik zu machen, ist wirklich erstaunlich neu. Gerade weil wir, eigentlich müsste man so vieles, Merkel arbeitet an ihrem eigenen Text gerade, eigentlich müsste man auch nochmal an dem Merkel-Text arbeiten. Aber man traut sich immer noch nicht ran, weil sie immer noch so unfassbar ist und ergreifbar irgendwie. Aber diese Zäsur, dieser große Schritt nach vorne, dass die Politik jetzt Aufklärung macht und Robert Habeck fünfminütige Videos macht, von denen wir wissen, die werden am Ende in 90-sekündige Beiträge verpackt, mit dem Anspruch, da auch noch andere Sichtweisen reinzubringen, obwohl man es nicht weiter komprimieren kann, als Habeck es gemacht hat. Also auch den Anspruch an den Bürger, also man kann den Anspruch weiter haben, aber man wird ihm nicht gerecht, das, was jetzt gerade passiert, in den bekannten Formaten zu erklären. Wir sehen hier, Habeck macht ein Angebot, das auch wirklich angenommen wird. Er hat sich damals von Twitter verabschiedet. Wir sagen ja immer irgendwie, Twitter ist halt die inhaltgetriebene Textplattform, Instagram ist Ästhetik und so weiter. Und jetzt zeigt uns Habeck, ne, auf Instagram erklärt man fünf Minuten lang, was Sache ist, und auf Twitter ist ja gar nicht mehr. Hat sich ja damals abgemeldet und kam nie wieder. Und das zeigt uns ja auch wieder, wie wir diese Social-Media-Einrichtung, wir kommen auch nachher noch mal auf Social-Media zu sprechen, wie wir das noch mal einzuschätzen haben. Vielleicht sollten wir uns echt alle kurz abmelden.
Weil das Argument vielleicht auf Twitter keinen Platz hat. Wir haben zwar die ganze Zeit Debatte, aber wir haben eigentlich keine Argumente. Wir haben immer Rückführungen jetzt bei all diesen offenen Briefen, egal aus welcher Ecke sie kommen, dass man sagt, der hat aber auch unterschrieben. Der hat auch unterschrieben. Oder wir hatten so einen Fall, dass Ali Schwartzer, von der ich nun jetzt wirklich kein Fan bin, aber deren Einlassung zum Krieg ich jetzt keineswegs skandalös finde, dass sie dann noch mal so, du hattest es, glaube ich, gepostet, 30 Sekunden vor Interviewende gefragt wird, ja, ist ihnen aufgefallen, dass die AfD ja auch Frieden will und keine Waffenlieferungen, wie grenzen sie sich von der AfD ab? Also dass man jetzt immer guckt, wer sagt was. Und da würde ich sagen, dann sind ja beide Seiten verloren. Also entweder beschäftigen wir uns mit dem Argument. Und das ist ja genau das, was Habermas anbietet. Jetzt bringe ich sie schon immer zusammen. Und Habeck bietet uns Argumente an und sagt, folgendermaßen könnte es gehen. Und dann könnte man da widersprechen und sagen, nein, man könnte Gas auch schon früher sich davon befreien, denn es gibt auch die und die Wege. Das ist einfach eine argumentative Sache. Und genauso kann ich sagen, Waffenlieferungen, ja oder nein, und kann über Argumente diskutieren. Zum Beispiel werden wir damit zu sehr zur wirklichen Kriegspartei und damit dann auch ein potenziales Angriff ziehen. Das sind ja Fragen, die man stellen kann. Wenn ich jetzt aber nur frage, von wem kommt das Argument, dann haben beide Seiten verloren. Denn dann kann ich zwar feststellen, gegen Waffenlieferungen ist auch ein AfD-Politiker oder wegen mir sehr viele sogar. Und ich kann aber auch feststellen, dass die, die für Waffenlieferungen sind, in einer Linie stehen mit Jan Fleischauer, Julian Reichelt, Boris Reitschuster und so weiter und so fort. Also mit Leuten, mit denen sie auch nichts zu tun haben wollen. Also wenn wir jetzt dahin gehen, da kommen wir überhaupt nicht mehr in eine Argumentation hinein. Und darum ginge es ja eigentlich, in eine Argumentation hineinzukommen. Aber das ist gar nicht gewünscht. Und vielleicht ist da dann bei Instagram, wo man eine gewisse Länge hat in Form dieser Videos, eine bessere Plattform.
Ja, es gibt ja einen sehr wunderbaren Begriff, um das Problem auf den Punkt zu bringen, was du jetzt beschrieben hast. Dunk Culture. Also wir kennen alle das Basketballspiel. Zwei Mannschaften, ein Ball, zwei Körbe. Man rennt aufeinander zu, versucht, den Ball oben reinzukriegen, schafft es dann vielleicht nicht. Der Ball prallt ab, hängt in der Luft, fliegt irgendwo hin. Keiner kann diesen Abpraller berechnen. Also springen einfach alle irgendwie hoch. Und einer schafft es, entweder den Ball einfach wegzuschlagen vom Korb oder noch schnell reinzudipsen. So den letzten Kick noch zu geben. Das ist dann der Dank, D-U-M-K. Und Joshua Tupolsky hatte das vor ein paar Jahren mal aufgegriffen in seinem Podcast, dass Twitter eigentlich Dank-Culture ist. Und es fiel mir jetzt auch wieder auf bei diesen offenen Briefen, während man bei Instagram einfach so durchscrollt, gar nichts mit Politik hat und plötzlich kommt das Argument. Und dann überlegt man sich, nehme ich mir da jetzt 5 Minuten für oder nicht? Und dann, wenn man weiterscrollt und sich dagegen entscheidet, bleibt aber auch Politik weiter hinten außen vor. Also es ist wirklich so ein, jetzt kommt das Argument, nimmst du es an, ja oder nein. Während man bei Twitter einfach noch reinliest, ach Ranga Yogeshwar hat sich auch dazu verhalten, ach Alice Schwarze auch. Und dann fragt man sich so nach 10 Tweets.
Jetzt bin ich enttäuscht von Ranga Yogeshwar schreiben, dann hunderte Leute.
Genau, und dann fragt man sich so nach ein paar Tweets, wozu eigentlich verhalten, worum geht es denn hier eigentlich? Und dann muss man aber noch ewig lange scrollen, bis man versteht, ah, es wurden offene Briefe geschrieben. So, dann die Frage, welche offenen Briefe? Wo kann ich die denn lesen? Also verlässt man dann Twitter, geht überhaupt erst mal woanders hin, zu Google zum Beispiel, googelt offene Brief, und kommt dann über, dass eigentlich schon zehn Leute versucht haben, den Dank zu verwandeln, kommt man dann überhaupt erst mal zum Argument. Und das ist natürlich bescheuert. Also damit hat man das Argument möglichst weit weggetrieben und hat sich verfangen in einer Kommunikation, die einem zu nichts führt, außer zu so einer emotionalen Aufladung. Weil das nach dieser zweijährigen Corona-Zeit, bei der vielen rangayogisch war, ans Herz gewachsen ist, sie jetzt plötzlich thematisch umschalten müssen, um sich neu zu dieser Person zu verhalten, ist ja auch so eine emotionale Kraftübung, die einfach bewältigt werden muss, die extrem viel Energie kostet und zu nichts führt. Weil dann hat man seine ganze Energie verbraucht und dann, ah, jetzt habe ich auch den Brief gefunden, jetzt kann ich überhaupt erst mal nachlesen, aber jetzt habe ich gar keine Lust mehr.
Muss man aber auch gleich wieder so einen Reinigungsprozess herstellen, dann muss man den jetzt auch canceln in dem Sinne. Also der ist jetzt raus. Der hat nämlich damals diesen Brief da unterschrieben, von dem ich gar nicht so genau weiß, was da drin steht. Und wenn man sich das mal ansieht, bis auf ein paar Formulierungen, würde man das gar nicht skandalisieren können. Aber das ist jetzt egal, denn Twitter hat mir eigentlich auch schon gesagt, was ich darüber denke bzw. was ich darüber fühlen soll. Und damit ist die Entscheidung schon gemacht. Das ist sehr, sehr eigenartig und auch unglaublich ermüdend. Von daher war das natürlich wieder eine goldrichtige Entscheidung von dir, dich diese Woche überhaupt nicht mit diesen Nachrichten zu beschäftigen. Die Debatte tobt aber zum Beispiel auch auf TikTok. Und ich will hier mal einen Clip spielen von einem TikTokker, den ich nicht kannte. Ich habe das geschickt bekommen von einem Bekannten. Und zwar ist es ja so, dass die ukrainischen Flüchtlinge jetzt sehr schnell integriert werden sollen in die deutsche Gesellschaft und in den Arbeitsmarkt. Und da ist ein TikTokker, der heißt Marwan Sayati, der 250.000 Follower hat. Marwan, wenn ich jetzt vom Namen ausgehe, hat also einen arabischen Ursprung, bezieht sich auch auf seinen Migrationshintergrund und äußert sich jetzt wie folgt auf TikTok.
Hey, was geht, Freunde? Mein Name ist Marwan und ich bringe euch heute die nicht so erfreulichen News. Und zwar hat die Tagesschau das folgende Foto heute auf ihrem Instagram gepostet. Studium ohne Schulabschluss soll geflüchteten ukrainischen SchülerInnen in Deutschland ermöglicht werden. Jetzt fragen sich bestimmt viele, oh mein Gott, wo ist das Problem, Marwan? Und Marwan sagt es euch jetzt. 150.000 syrische Menschen sind 2015 nach Deutschland geflüchtet und die haben dieses Angebot nicht bekommen. Das ist natürlich nicht alles. Hier haben wir die Top-Asyl-Herkunftsländer 2021. Syrien mit 70.000 Asylanträgen in 2021 noch. In 2021 Afghanistan 31.000, Irak 16.000. Wo bleibt dieses Angebot für diese Menschen, frage ich mich. Jetzt, wo es ein europäisches Land gibt, das in Not ist, und das ist sehr tragisch, kann Deutschland schön den Freunden und Helfern spielen. Aber als die Menschen aus Syrien, Irak, Afghanistan, Türkei, was auch immer, hier hingeflüchtet sind, gab es dieses Angebot nicht. Woran liegt das? Als Migrantenkind in Deutschland zu leben, ist einfach nur erschütternd, wirklich. Das ist einfach nur traurig. Uns wird jeden Tag diese brutale Realität vor Augen gehalten und uns wird immer wieder gezeigt, wie privilegiert weiße Menschen in Deutschland sind.
Diese Doppelstandards werden viel zu wenig verhandelt. Sie finden aber dann auf TikTok statt und erreichen da richtig viele Leute. Das ist dann aus der Community heraus Leute, die eigentlich mit anderen Inhalten dort stattfinden, aber die das jetzt thematisieren, weil denen das ja auffällt. Auch gerade Leute, die ich jetzt kenne, die sich sehr für syrische Flüchtlinge engagiert hatten, die zum Beispiel einen Flüchtling betreut hatten, der Anfang 20, Mitte 20 war, schon ein Studium, ein mit dem Master vergleichbares Studium abgeschlossen hatte und der dann hier erstmal überhaupt nichts anerkannt bekam, wo man ihn am liebsten nochmal in die 8. Klasse zurückgestellt hätte, die dann lange kämpfen mussten, dass er dann hier gleich mit der Universität anfangen kann und nicht noch irgendeinen Abitur nachholen kann, aber trotzdem natürlich ganz viele Jahre verliert. Und das ist für die natürlich jetzt auch eine ganz schwierige Situation, dass sie da so hart kämpfen mussten. Und dass das jetzt als selbstverständlich angesehen wird, weil das ja sagt, das hätten wir natürlich bei den anderen auch machen können, aber da hat uns das nicht interessiert. Und das ist auch etwas, was, glaube ich, nicht gerade einen gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt hervorbringt.
Also riesiges Problem, dass wir immer wieder, das ist ja sozusagen dieser strukturelle Rassismus einfach, der natürlich in vielen Ländern, auch in Amerika, jetzt so kontrovers diskutiert wird, dass man wieder keinen ordentlichen Boden unter den Füßen findet. Ich gucke jetzt immer punktuell so ein bisschen mit Türkisch für Anfänger. Ich weiß nicht, ob du die Serie kennst. Das ist so klassisches für meine 12-jährige Programm irgendwie. Und da wird es immer wieder ganz clever thematisiert, ohne es zu groß aufzubauschen, sondern einfach nur so in so ganz kleinen Alltagsdingern. Und da finde ich es dann super präsent. Und so sollte man es auch, finde ich, also da habe ich so gedacht, ja, stimmt. Anstatt dass man jetzt immer so ein Seminar macht zum Thema Rassismus und so weiter, muss man es einfach in dem Moment, wo es passiert, in so ganz kleinen Sachen, müsste man es eigentlich immer für alle vergegenwärtigen und nicht nur für die Opfer. Das wäre irgendwie so, dass man, keine Ahnung, gerade bei TikTok gibt es auch so verschiedene Zeichen für Frauen, die dann irgendwie ihre Hand so und so halten und dann ihrem Publikum zu erkennen geben oder sich das auf TikTok zeigen, wie man das macht, wenn man in einem Gespräch ist und dann eine spezifische Handhaltung hält, dass das dann so Hilferufe sind und so. Und eigentlich bräuchte man so kleine Interventionssymbole, dass man einfach in sozialen Situationen, wo man gerade wieder mal Opfer wird, irgendwie darauf hinweist. Aber nicht zu explizit, sondern nur für die, die es erkennen wollen, so ein Zeichen hinterlässt, hier findet gerade Rassismus statt. Irgendwie so, dass man schon die Rassismus-Kommunikation mal integriert in den Alltag und nicht immer so abschiebt ins Seminarraum hier und Awareness-Dings da und politische Programme da drüben und so weiter. Aber es ist, wie soll man sagen, das ist wirklich wahnsinnig kompliziert. Aber er hat natürlich Vollrecht.
Wir haben Alexander Kluge in der vergangenen Folge gehabt und da gab es diese Formulierung von ihm, man muss den Krieg zum Stolpern bringen. Und der Moderator stutzte auch erst. Kluge hat es dann an mehreren Beispielen erzählt. Wir haben den Podcast aufgenommen. Ich komme nach Hause, gehe zu Twitter und sehe dann folgenden Tagesschaubeitrag, aus dem wir uns jetzt einen kurzen Clip anhören.
Valentina Petrivna hat nun wirklich ihren Beitrag geleistet, dafür, dass Kiew nicht in russischer Hand ist. Kommt rein und schaut euch das an, sagt die 61-Jährige, und legt uns schnell noch ein Brett aus, damit wir halbwegs durchkommen durch ihr Grundstück aus Schlamm. Und ran an ihren Garten, der eher einem See gleicht. Ich bin jeden Tag aufgewacht, das Wasser stieg und stieg. Ich habe mich gefragt, ob ich noch zum Stall komme, um die Kuh zu füttern. So wie Valentina geht es vielen in Demidorf rund 30 km nördlich von Kiew. Wasser überall. Der kleine Ort wurde bewusst geflutet, um den russischen Vormarsch zu stoppen. Lieber Wasser im Dorf als Russen, sagen sie hier. Natürlich ist das jetzt eine heiden Arbeit, aber was soll ich machen? Das Wasser geht wieder weg. Wir aber haben Kiew gerettet und wurden nicht bombardiert.
Ja, ist so ein bisschen das Gegenteil von der Brücke sprengen. Da muss man auch durch Wasser durch. Jetzt wird ja einfach geflutet, das Wasser wird geholt, statt die Brücke abgebaut.
Ja, sehr schön. Also noch mal als Beispiel, dass wir es bei Alexander Klugenlich einfach mit einem Poeten zu tun haben, der uns schöne Bilder liefert, sondern der ganz konkret sagt, so kann man auch den Krieg anders verlaufen lassen oder zum Stolpern bringen. Da wurde es gemacht und gleich in der Tagesschau konnte man es sich dann ansehen, wie da alles unter Wasser steht. Gut, wir haben ja viel vor. Wir sprechen über das Buch Das Ende des Endes der Geschichte, untertitelt Postpolitik, Antipolitik und der Zerfall der liberalen Demokratie. Ich sage es mal so provokant, es ist auch eine Analyse von woke Twitter, aber noch sehr, sehr viel mehr. Ich bin sehr begeistert von diesem Buch und bin gespannt, was du dazu zu sagen hast.
Also es richtet sich ja auch ein bisschen gegen uns, finde ich. Also gegen alle. Es ist so ein ganz breiter Rundumschluss.
Im Prinzip auch, ja.
Auch gegen uns. Wie Neo, der einfach mal die Latte rausholt und gegen alle einfach mal so im Kreis schlägt, blind links. Ich habe es einmal gelesen und dachte dann, habe ich jetzt verstanden, was ich meine oder nicht? Und dann habe ich überlegt, lese ich es jetzt nochmal oder lasse ich das einfach so stehen? Und informiere mich aber nochmal über Bande. Was hat Fukuyama damals geschrieben? Was sagt er jetzt gerade auch zum Krieg zum Beispiel? Deswegen heute ist es ein bisschen anders. Sonst verlasse ich mich ja immer sehr auf das Buch und dann besprechen wir einfach das Buch. Heute bringe ich mal noch ein bisschen Kontext und Kulisse mit in der Hoffnung, dass uns das irgendwie hilft. Mal sehen, ich bin gespannt.
Sehr gut. Dann sprechen wir noch kurz über das Buch Die Zukunft des Luxus von Erwan Rambourg. Da brauchen wir glaube ich nicht so lange für. Aber so ein paar Aspekte sind vielleicht doch drin. Demografisch, geopolitisch lässt sich da das eine oder andere sicherlich sagen.
Richtig. Also selten ein Buch gelesen, in dem die Rentenabublik mal einfach so mit durchgeschleift wird. Das war ganz erstaunlich so zu sehen. Ich habe dann aber auch nur punktuell. Also ich habe diese Interviews zum Beispiel nicht gelesen. Und nur diese thematischen Kapitel dazu. Was hast du sonst noch? Wir machen einen Spaziergang durch Japan. Es ist vielleicht einer der schönsten Texte überhaupt. Ich habe ihn jetzt einfach nur in den inhaltlichen Aspekten für uns so übersetzt, dass man mal darüber reden kann, was da drin steht. Aber es ist einer der poetischen Rentenrepublikstexte, der mir bis jetzt untergekommen ist. Auf höhere Empfehlungen von Hendrik. Gerne aufgegriffen und dann folgt ein Experiment. Und zwar habe ich, das ist ganz witzig, in der Welt ein Interview mit dem Bauingenieur Werner Sobeck. Das ist super lang und super interessant, denn er ist einer der Verfechter einer neuen Baukultur und sagt danach, mit dem Holz noch mal nachdenken, Beton noch mal neu machen und so weiter. Er geht den populären Sachen auf den Grund und widerspricht da auch noch mal. Und jetzt habe ich den Text heute Morgen aufgerufen, er ist zack hinter einer Paywall verschwunden, was bedeutet, dass meine Instapaper, digitale Kopie, jetzt mit Buchstabensalat verschlüsselt ist und ich nur noch die von mir im Text markierten Textstellen habe. Ich kann nicht mehr auf den ganzen Text zugreifen, sondern nur noch auf meine 50 oder 60. Ich habe es nochmal durchgescrollt, es würde reichen, um zu reproduzieren, was da drin steht, aber es wird ein kleines Experiment. Naja, und dann haben die bei netzpolitik.org, die haben eine interessante Reihe zum digitalen Kolonialismus. Kolonialismus. Und da gucken wir in den aktuellen Text von Satyajit Malik über, wie Facebook jetzt doch geschafft hat, den Indian-Fuß zu fassen, nachdem sie da herausgeschmissen wurden. Also hochinteressant und auch ein bisschen gruselig, ehrlich gesagt.
Sehr gut. Ich werde über den Habermas-Essay sprechen oder die Intervention in der Süddeutschen Zeitung. Ich habe sogar auf Papier gelesen, Stefan, noch richtig Zeitung hier. Ja, und zwar auf zwei Seiten hat man das gedruckt.
Und man hat hier Spalten, oder?
Und man hat hier Raum gelassen. Nur vier Spalten hat aber wirklich gesagt, hier ist jetzt das Ereignis. Habermas beschäftigt sich mit dem Krieg im hohen Alter. Er thematisiert auch zweimal sein Alter. Ein hochinteressanter Text, wie ich finde. Dann, wie schon angekündigt, diese Dokumentation in den Blättern über das, was die Russen da als Entnazifizierung der Ukraine bezeichnen. Dann geht es um eine Studie aus Baden-Württemberg, wo wollen junge Menschen eigentlich leben? Nun, die wollen schon auch sehr gern auf dem Land leben, stellt sich da heraus. Dann werden wir uns den Roman Die Neuen von Madame Nielsen ansehen. Ein toller Liebesroman. Und dann noch als kleines Amuse-Gueule ein Interview, ein sehr langes Interview mit Udo Kier.
Udo Kier ist wer noch mal?
Udo Kier ist der Schauspieler, der in über 200 Filmen mitgespielt hat.
Ich habe ihn vor Augen, glaube ich.
Der Lieblings-Schauspieler von Lars von Trier. Du hast ihn schon ganz oft gesehen, aber der oft sehr kleine Rollen spielt, mit Andy Warhol befreundet war und unglaublich viele Anekdoten zu berichten hat.
Er spielt, glaube ich, den Vampir in Underworld. So ein Obervampir, bin ich ganz sicher.
Er hat auch nicht nur einmal einen Vampir gespielt.
Es sieht jedenfalls sehr gut aus.
Wir sehen uns also jetzt im Salon, den man entweder über Steady buchen kann und auch über Apple. Es hat sich zumindest jetzt niemand beschwert, dass irgendetwas nicht funktioniert hat bei Apple. Wir präferieren weiterhin Steady, weil dann auch alle anderen alten Folgen ganz einfach abrufbar sind und ein paar andere Möglichkeiten noch bestehen. Es ist auch ein bisschen günstiger als Apple, weil Apple natürlich immer auch noch mitverdienen will. Aber beide Varianten sind uns recht, solange der Podcast so unterstützt wird und der Salon gehört wird. Bis gleich.